this is the latest stop on prince
harry's journey out of the realm of
working royal
and if the offices of his new employer
remain shuttered
due to the pandemic the real world
concerns of life in san francisco
very much on the doorstep but prince
harry now appears on the website of
better up
as its new chief impact officer welcome
to growth and
transformation with betterup where every
employee builds the skills
mindsets and behaviors needed to perform
at their peak
he was actually a client himself in
contact with one of the personal coaches
they say
can make employees feel more positive
engaged and connected
the app's founder explained what a
prince can bring
we were just so impressed and really um
i think there was such a natural
chemistry and synergy around
the insights and the contributions he
can make creativity
to better up in ensuring that we achieve
our mission so what is a chief impact
officer
bigger than commercial success this is
about global impact and so as we
crafted the role together um again those
four buckets of opportunities
we came to the tile of chief impact
officer really denoting that he's
focused on our mission and he's focused
on ensuring that we're doing everything
we can
to achieve our mission on a bigger and
larger and grander scale to impact the
lives of more people
they haven't disclosed how much the duke
will earn or what the terms of his
contract will be but then as he's a
private citizen
now why would they they have said this
isn't just
a celebrity joining the board of
directors he's coming as an executive
who will work
attending meetings and company events he
has said
he wants to help have an impact on
people's lives
whatever when the duke does come here
for meetings they'll be a warm welcome
we're open open you know to everybody
kind of coming coming to the city and
you know kind of you know having having
their hand and and making it uh
making it better if that happens he's
sensational
we're lucky to have him that's how i
feel i think that's how a lot of us feel
i read that this morning hearing that he
um
was going to with mental health right so
hearing that is also really great
considering his wife's situation i think
that's a really great step forward
for many americans that interview not
only generated headlines it introduced
them to the sussex brand
and brought a hefty amount of sympathy
and support a new job
another sign they are well and truly now
a fixture of american life
greg milam sky news san francisco